JEZ FLETCHER: All right.
Good afternoon, everyone, and
welcome to this session, which
is called "How to Build
Multi-platform Maps with
Google's APIs." My name's
Jez Fletcher.
I'm a software engineer
on the Google Maps API
team based in Sydney.
ENOCH LAU: Hi.
I'm Enoch Lau, and I'm a
software engineer also in
Sydney on the Google
Maps API team.
JEZ FLETCHER: So we thought we'd
start out this afternoon
with some reasons why you should
be in this session as
opposed to any of the other
sessions that are
currently going on.
We know that Google I/O's an
exciting time, and there's a
lot of sessions vying
for your time.
So one good reason why you
should be here is if you have
a successful mapping
application,
perhaps on one platform--
let's say you have a
successful Android
application--
and you'd like to bring it to
other platforms, and you want
to know the principles that you
should follow to make this
as seamless as possible to
do this cross-platform
development.
ENOCH LAU: Alternatively, you're
starting from scratch.
You're building a new
application, and you want to
target it for Android, iOS,
and the web together.
JEZ FLETCHER: What we're not
going to do in this session is
do any sort of deep dive into
the code of any of the
particular platforms.
There was a great talk yesterday
on iOS mapping using
the new iOS SDK, and there's
another session directly
following this on Android and
mapping that's going to go
really deep into the
code and so forth.
So we thought we'd start out
with a look at what the
picture was 12 months ago
if you wanted to do
cross-platform mapping
development.
And the answer is that it was
somewhat limited compared to
what it is now.
We had the JavaScript Maps API,
which you can see on the
left there.
This was actually designed
to work on mobile
devices quite well.
But it was only one application,
and it didn't
have a lot of the cool things
that the newer SDKs do.
We also had v1 of the Java
MapView for Android, which was
also limited.
It wasn't really well supported,
and it was missing
some of the modern features that
are in the newer ones.
ENOCH LAU: Now if you fast
forward to today, we now have
an SDK on iOS for you to write
your maps on iPad and iPhone.
And now we have version two of
the Android Maps API, which is
really beautiful.
It has 3D graphics, tilt, vector
graphics, all that
lovely stuff.
And of course, the JavaScript
Maps API is still going strong
for all your web application
needs.
JEZ FLETCHER: So one of the
things that we're going to be
coming back to quite a lot in
this talk is that everything
is a balancing act.
Now this is particularly
true when you're doing
cross-platform development,
because you're going to be
looking a lot at trade-offs.
You're going to be looking at
when things should go in the
frontend, when they should go
in the backend, you're going
to have to do a lot with UI
things that may be trading off
between different paradigms
that you want to follow.
So this is a common theme that
we're going to come back to a
number of times during
the talk.
ENOCH LAU: So this talk
is in four parts.
First of all, we're going to
talk about some of the
challenges that you might
experience as you develop maps
on three different platforms.
JEZ FLETCHER: In the second
part, we're going to talk
about some good guiding
principles for doing
cross-platform development
in mapping applications.
And in the process of doing
this, we hope to provide you
with some solutions
to the challenges
of the first section.
ENOCH LAU: Thirdly, we'll
continue down the path of
talking about some principles,
and we're going to take a deep
dive into backend infrastructure
and how you can
best structure your backend
infrastructure so that writing
apps in three different
platforms is more efficient
and more easy for you to do.
JEZ FLETCHER: And in the fourth
section, we're going to
invite Jack Kwok, who's a
software architect with
Trulia, to come up and talk
about Trulia's experience
dealing with making mapping
applications that run across
multiple platforms.
ENOCH LAU: So let begin by
looking at some of the
challenges that you might
experience as you develop
mapping applications in
multiple platforms.
First of all, there is the
question of effort.
So clearly if you have three
different code bases targeting
three different platforms, and
each is written independently
of each other, that's
a lot more effort.
And what is effort?
Effort is time.
And what is time?
Time is money.
So there's a question of, should
I put more effort in
and get a greater reward
potentially?
But perhaps there's also greater
risk there as well.
JEZ FLETCHER: One of the next
challenges with dealing in
multiple platforms is dealing
with the different use cases
across different platforms.
Obviously, people are going
to use a desktop device
differently to how they're going
to use a mobile device.
And there's also subtle
differences in the way that
particular platforms, even
different mobile
platforms, are used.
ENOCH LAU: Next is the challenge
of thinking about
what are the capabilities
of the
platform that you're targeting.
So each platform clearly has
its own strengths and
weaknesses.
On the web, you typically have
people at a desktop computer
with a big screen real
estate, lots of space
for you to work with.
But on a mobile device, less
screen real estate.
You have less space
to work with.
But there are unique
capabilities that mobile
offers, like GPS, storage in the
device, cameras, all that
kind of stuff.
And as you remember from the
keynote yesterday, Android now
has greatly new location APIs,
a great new geofencing API.
And you can take advantage of
these when you're writing an
application for Android.
JEZ FLETCHER: Yeah.
The other thing to think about
is the user experience.
And when we talk about the user
experience, we're talking
about matching up with the way
user actually wants to
interact with your
application.
This is particularly important
when you're dealing with a
mapping application, because
there are certain ways that
people want to interact with
a mapping application.
There are certain things that
they expect it to do, and
there are certain ways that
want they want to use it.
So ensuring that you have a good
user experience is really
quite important.
ENOCH LAU: So let's now take a
look at some of the principles
that you might follow as you
address some of these
challenges, and we might provide
some solutions that
might apply to your
situation as well.
So to address the problem
about effort versus risk
versus reward, you need to
work with your budget.
You need to understand what are
the business constraints
for your particular
organization.
So every organization is
going to be different.
Perhaps your organization
has more resources, more
manpower, more time.
In that case, maybe developing
three separate applications is
the right way to go.
You're going to end up with
a really slick, beautiful
experience on each particular
platform.
On the other hand, if
you have limited
resources, limited power--
maybe you need to get to
market really quickly--
then maybe you just
write it once.
And here's an example of
what you could do.
Using the JavaScript Maps API,
perhaps you just write the
mapping application once.
Obviously, it works beautifully
in a web browser
for desktop.
But then you can also embed this
JavaScript implementation
into a web view so that you
can put the same mapping
implementation into a native
Android application.
Alternatively, you could just
have your users navigate to
mycompany.com, and then build
a beautiful website.
That works really well too.
JEZ FLETCHER: But you'd
say this is a
balancing act, right?
Because obviously, there are
advantages and disadvantages
to both sides.
ENOCH LAU: That's right.
It's a balancing act.
JEZ FLETCHER: So you need
to make that decision.
It is a balancing act.
So the next point is recognizing
the use cases.
Now I talked a little bit before
about that there are
different use cases, and really
the only thing you can
do as a developer is to work
out what they are.
Do some research.
Find out how your users are
going to be using your
application.
Now the key point here, perhaps,
is the difference
between a desktop application
and a mobile application.
Obviously, when someone's using
a desktop application,
they're in a different mode to
when they're using a mobile
application.
If you're using a mobile
application, you're
often out and about.
You're often doing something
that requires an immediate
answer, and you're doing
something that needs to be
more focused to the
task at hand.
When you're on a desktop device,
you're perhaps doing
more research.
You're perhaps doing a more time
intensive and more full
study of the task that you're
trying to perform.
ENOCH LAU: So as a great example
of this, here's a
screen shot from Expedia's
website on desktop.
And you can see they've taken
advantage of the screen real
estate afforded to
them on desktop.
For the hotels, there's great
detail about each.
There's ratings, price, all of
this stuff in a tabular view
that's great for research.
And then if you focus your
attention to the left panel,
you see that there are many
options to drill down and
really focus your search.
So you can select from ratings,
location price.
There's a little map
there as well.
So they've taking the screen
real estate given to them and
provided tools to the user such
that it's really powerful
for them when they're searching
for hotels.
JEZ FLETCHER: Now conversely,
these are some shots from
Expedia's Android application,
which is really great.
And what they do here is that
they really focused down the
tasks that they're trying
to deliver.
So on the left, you can
see this is their
flight search page.
And not only is it a lot more
streamlined and a lot more
clean than the desktop
application, but it also takes
advantage of the capabilities
of the system.
You can see here it's
automatically picked up
Oakland and San Francisco
Airport as nearby airports and
has put them to the top.
So you don't have to type in
an airport code to find
flights from your
local airports.
On the right hand side, you can
see the hotel search page,
and this is really quite
different to the desktop
experience.
Here, everything is focused
on the map.
You can get things from your
current location, and you can
also do this filtering.
But what they've done is they've
really cut back their
filtering options, and they've
made it a lot more streamlined
and a lot more focused than it
was when you had all of those
options when you have
a desktop device.
ENOCH LAU: So one other
principle that you can take
into heart is you need to
focus on the correct UI
paradigms for your particular
platform.
And what we mean by that is
there's a balancing act
between cross-platform
consistency--
that is, between your various
apps on the different
platforms--
and intra-platform
consistency--
that is, between your
app and other
apps on the same platform.
So as an example of this--
JEZ FLETCHER: So that's a really
good example of what we
mean by cross-platform
consistency.
When we're talking about that,
we want to make sure that our
app feels like it's the same
app, that it works the way it
should across your different
platforms.
A great example of how you can
do this really nicely is by
using Google's mapping
and web services.
So obviously, if you have the
same data across your
different devices, then you're
going to get the same results.
If you use the searches for
a bunch of addresses on a
desktop device, you can be
confident that those addresses
are going to be exactly the
same on a mobile device.
So the example we have here is
some directions across the
country, and you can see
that they get rendered
exactly the same way.
They're exactly the same route
between the desktop device and
the mobile device.
And because users are going to
be switching between the two,
having this kind of consistency
across the
platform is really
quite important.
ENOCH LAU: So by contrast,
here's what we mean by
intra-platform consistency.
And a great example of this is
to look at the Back button on
each particular platform.
So on the left here, we have
a screenshot from iOS.
And typically in an iPhone
application, your Back button
goes in the top of the corner.
So if you're developing a
mapping application for iOS,
it makes sense to put it on the
top of the corner, this
Back button.
On the other hand, on Android,
the Back button is typically
provided by the operating
system.
There's a soft button on
the bottom left corner.
So you want to follow these UI
paradigms for that particular
platform so that your
application feels as though it
belongs in that particular
ecosystem of apps.
JEZ FLETCHER: Yeah.
It's really quite awkward.
ENOCH LAU: And there's nothing
worse than opening your
Android phone and seeing apps
that look like iOS on an
Android phone.
It's a little bit grating,
isn't it.
JEZ FLETCHER: Yeah.
Nothing worse than that.
ENOCH LAU: Nothing
worse than that.
JEZ FLETCHER: Actually, I can
think of a few things worse
than that, but that's
definitely in
my top 10, I'd say.
All right.
Now let's have a look at some
of the principles of the
backend infrastructure that
can really make your
development seamless between
different platforms.
ENOCH LAU: So one key effective
aspect of strong
backend infrastructure is to
have a shared data store.
So it'd be surprising and really
weird if on a desktop
you could search for
restaurants, but then you get
a different set of restaurants
if you search
on your mobile device.
That would be weird.
That might seem obvious.
But a more key point is that for
user data, that needs to
be a persistent in a way
that's cross platform.
So if the user is on your
restaurant-searching website,
and they save a list of
locations, ideally he or she
would be able to get that list
of locations on their mobile
device when they're
out and about.
JEZ FLETCHER: The next key point
is that you should push
functionality to the server
side where it makes sense.
If you're doing something that's
common to all of your
platforms, then it makes sense
to push this logic to the
server side.
The advantage of this is
that you only have to
implement it once.
You don't have to implement it
multiple times for multiple
different platforms.
The other key thing that really
helps it pushing server
side is if you're
doing anything
computationally intensive.
If you're doing, say, some sort
of analysis over a very
large data set, then this might
take a great deal of
computing time.
So it makes sense to leverage
the backend architecture that
you have at your advantage
rather than putting this to
the device.
The other thing is if you're
doing a lot of computation on,
say, a mobile device, you're
going to really minimize the
battery life.
And that's going to
annoy your users.
ENOCH LAU: And then when you
put all this data on the
server side, where
do you store it?
You can store it in Google
Maps Engine.
JEZ FLETCHER: Oh, yeah.
That's a really, really
good idea.
So if you haven't actually had a
play with Google Maps Engine
yet, you can sign up for an
account at the Maps Sandbox.
We'll be there afterwards, and
you can come talk to us and
sign up for an account.
ENOCH LAU: So if you have a
strong backend infrastructure,
how do you get your clients
to talk to it?
And a really key point is that
you should use a shared
communication format.
So suppose today you're
only talking in web.
That's fine.
But then, if your website
talks to your
server using JSON--
JavaScript Object Notation--
then if you add another client--
let's say you added
an Android application.
If that Android application
spoke in the same format,
JSON, then your server wouldn't
need to be changed.
The sever would then be agnostic
as the client that is
talking to it.
And then, you can add additional
clients with less
effort if all of these spoke
in the same format.
And other formats include XML,
GeoJSON, which is a particular
variant of JSON which is great
for geographic data.
JEZ FLETCHER: So following on
from that shared communication
format, if you cleanly separate
your frontend from
your backend, then you're
going to have a lot less
trouble with the actual
development.
A good guide is to put things
only in the application which
need to be in the application.
They need to be application
specific for
that particular platform.
Then you can push all
of the rest of your
logic to your backend.
The advantage of doing this is
that it really makes you think
about the interface that you're
exposing to your clients.
And once you have a nice clean
interface, it's really easy to
add more clients
in the future.
So as Enoch said, your server
can be agnostic about the
clients that it's serving.
The clients only need to know
about the logic for their
particular platform, and they
need to know how to
communicate with the server
on the same interface.
ENOCH LAU: So now one of
advantage of using Google web
services is that there
are so many of them.
You can use Geocoding.
There's Directions.
There's Distance Matrix, Places
Search-- a whole slew
of web services.
JEZ FLETCHER: Slew.
Elevation too.
No one ever mentions
Elevation.
I love Elevation.
ENOCH LAU: But there's a
slew of web services.
JEZ FLETCHER: Slew.
Stop saying "slew."
ENOCH LAU: So what you can do
with these web services is you
can query from the client side,
but you can also query
them from the server
side as well.
And here's an example of what
you could do if you have
strong backend infrastructure
that leverages
Google's web services.
So let's say that
you're querying
Google's geocoding service.
You're querying the Places
Search service, right?
And then, you have some
special sauce.
You have some really interesting
logic that
combines these two pieces
of information together.
You can also combine some of
your own data as well.
And then, your server can
combine it in this interesting
fashion that you come up and
then send the result back to
the client.
And by putting it into the
server, you don't have to
write it three times for each
of the clients, right?
And you also improve network
latency, because each of your
clients, they won't need to
talk to three separate
backends and then combine
it in the client.
JEZ FLETCHER: So let's
reiterate some of the
principles we're talking about
when we're talking about
backend infrastructure.
The first is to have this clean
separation from your
frontend and your backend.
So everything that needs to be
in the frontend should be in
the frontend.
Everything that needs
to be in the backend
should be in the backend.
And you should have a clean
interface between the two.
ENOCH LAU: Your apps should
communicate in the same way,
so that your backends can be
agnostic and you can add new
clients easily.
JEZ FLETCHER: And finally,
you should push
computationally-intensive
or common
functionality to the server.
You only have to implement it
once, and you can leverage all
of the power of your backends.
ENOCH LAU: You know, in
the end, everything
is a balancing act.
Your case is going to be
special, and you need to think
about how you're going to
balance these things.
As this turtle knows, he needs
to think about should he put
more effort into the frontend
or the backend--
I say the frontend--
or he's going to put more
effort in a trade-off--
JEZ FLETCHER: Did you just come
up with that frontend and
backend thing?
ENOCH LAU: Maybe I did.
Alternatively, he needs to
think about a trade-off
between effort and
risk and reward.
I'm sure he wants to put more
effort in, so he doesn't crush
that little poor
guy down there.
But everything is
a balancing act.
JEZ FLETCHER: And with that,
we'd like to invite Jack Kwok
from Trulia to come up on stage
to discuss Trulia's
experiences with doing
multi-platform development.
[APPLAUSE]
JACK KWOK: Thank you, Jez.
JEZ FLETCHER: Thanks.
JACK KWOK: [INAUDIBLE]
Good afternoon, everyone.
My name is Jack Kwok.
I'm the mobile architect
at Trulia.
At Trulia, we have built over
a dozen native mobile
applications along with our
website to make it really easy
for consumers to find
the perfect home.
Buying a house is a huge
decision, and we have built
some really great map-enhanced
features to help.
The homebuying experience
is inherently mobile.
Today, we have applications
across Android phone, tablets,
iPhone, iPad, and more.
Today, I'm going to share with
you some of the techniques and
principles that we have followed
in building an
amazing map experience across
different platforms.
So at Trulia, we understand that
a great user experience
is key to an awesome app, and
a responsive UI keeps our
users engaged.
I'll share a couple of
techniques later on how to
really speed up the
map interactions.
Another principle that we have
followed is we design our
backend API, web service
API, to be completely
device-agnostic.
So all our apps speak
the same JSON format
with our backend services.
You really want avoid a
situation where you are
returning specific custom data
based on the device type.
The reason is with a
device-independent API, it
really simplifies your
maintenance and testing.
And even if you're just creating
for one platform
today, once your app becomes
successful, you'll want to be
able to scale across different
platforms really quickly.
So let's see some examples.
At Trulia, we give you the
inside scoop on what it's like
to live in a neighborhood.
What you're looking at
is our Crime Map.
The red area indicates
area of high crime.
As you zoom in, more detail
emerges, just
as you would expect.
We have brought the Crime Map
experience to the iPad as well
as on Android phones
and tablets.
Commuting sucks.
Nobody wants to be stuck
in a traffic jam.
Our Commute Map is the
visualization of commute
times, driving times, as well
as public transit times from
any location.
Users simply drag the marker
and drop it at any location
they want, and a
dynamically-generated heat map
is generated on the fly and
placed on top of Google Maps.
We are bringing the same Commute
Map experience to
Android as well.
One really cool feature about
the Android Maps SDK is the 3D
functionalities, so all of the
markers and your custom
overlays are automatically
transformed 3D with no
additional work involved from
the developer side, as the
users tilt and rotate
with gestures.
So at Trulia, we have data on
over 100 million homes.
Our data scientists use
machine-learning algorithms to
create models and visualizations
of home values
down to the block level.
So how do all these heat
map tiles work?
A heat map is implemented in
a tile overlay, and a tile
overlay is a two-dimensional
grid of tiles.
On the right, you see that
I've highlighted the
individual tiles with
a red border.
And each tile is a square
image, a 256-pixel by
256-pixel image uniquely
identified by three numbers--
a zoom level, an x-position, and
a y-position, like the URL
you see at the bottom.
So typically, out backend
service would process and
normalize some external data--
sometimes in XML format--
and we would use mapping to
generate the tiles in a
device-agnostic way.
In fact, all our devices
and our website use
the same set of tiles.
So one thing to keep in mind is
even though you can add in
the opacity in the browser with
the JavaScript API, on
Android, there's no efficient
way to do that.
So when you're generating your
tiles, you probably want to
bake in the opacity, so that you
can have one set of tiles
working across all your devices
and your website.
So on Android, it's pretty
simple to add a tile overlay.
You simply extend a
URLTileProvider class to let
the Maps SDK know where to
fetch your custom tiles.
If you want more customized
ability, like customizing the
caching behavior, you can
implement the tile provider
interface yourself.
And for iOS, if you downloaded
the latest version, which was
released yesterday, there are
new tile overlay capabilities
that are very similar
to Android.
So I really like how Google
Maps takes care of all the
Mercator projection
math for me.
It's so simple to add
a tile overlay.
It takes maybe 20 lines of code
to add it into mobile.
So the Google Maps SDK for
Android and iOS actually share
very similar abstractions, like
camera position, ground
overlay, markers, polyline,
polygons, et cetera.
So if you're developing for
both iOS and Android, you
appreciate the consistency of
working with similar classes
across the platforms.
One really key thing about
making a great user experience
with tiles is a really robust
caching strategy.
At Trulia, we cache the tile
images at three levels--
at the tile server, at the
content uniform network, and
finally at the device
local storage.
So caching is especially
important for tiles that don't
update regularly.
So for the crime tiles that I
showed you earlier, they're
only updated once a month.
So there's no reason to refetch
the tiles every time
from your mobile device.
It would just waste bandwidth.
So at Trulia, we want
to make search fun.
We added Draw Search to
the browser first.
You click the upper right corner
to enable Draw Search,
and each mouse click on the
map marks a vertex of the
search polygon.
And you double click to close
the polygon, and within a
couple of seconds, you get
some results back.
On the mobile, the experience
is much more natural.
You simply draw with
you finger a path
of the search area.
So when we first built a
prototype on iPad, we noticed
it was taking a really long time
for results to come back.
So after some investigation, we
found that the bottleneck
was due to the large number of
vertexes collected in the path
the user traced with the
touch interface.
So we came up with a solution
by plugging in a polygon
simplification algorithm, which
is an algorithm that
reduces the number of vertexes
while at the same time
preserving the general
shape of the polygon.
So you think since this is
a mobile-specific issue,
shouldn't this be implemented
on a device side?
Well, in fact, it's much more
efficient if we push that into
the backend.
And there's a few benefits
to that.
First, you don't have to write
a code like Java code on
Android and then port the
same thing writing
Objective-C on iOS.
And second, if we needed to
tweak or optimize the
geospatial algorithm, we just
need to do it in the backend.
There's no need to
push an update to
individual app stores.
And finally, it saves users'
battery life by not doing some
complicated floating-point
operations on the device.
So three key takeaways
for today.
Through all the intensive and
shared functionalities, we
pushed all of that
into the backend.
Design a platform-agnostic API
so that you can scale to
multiple platforms quickly.
And finally, design a robust
caching strategy for a great
map experience.
I hope you have learned a few
techniques today in building
your own great map experience
on multiple platforms.
With that, I'd like to invite
back Jez and Enoch back up on
stage for a Q&A session.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
JEZ FLETCHER: If you do have
questions, please come to the
microphones, because it's
being recorded.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Quick question
about geofencing.
Is that available on iOS
and in the JavaScript
implementations, or is
it strictly Android?
JEZ FLETCHER: So right now,
it's part of Google Play
services, which is only
available on Android.
I don't know of anything similar
for other things.
iOS has something similar?
It does not have it.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JEZ FLETCHER: Yes.
ENOCH LAU: But in addition, you
could use the Tracks API.
You can analyze the data
afterwards and do something
similar as well if
you have that.
AUDIENCE: I guess the second
thing is, the geofence, can
you tie it to a polygon,
or is it simply a
point with a radius?
JEZ FLETCHER: That's
a good question.
I actually don't know
the answer to that.
If you come talk to us
afterwards, we can probably
find someone who knows.
AUDIENCE: All right, thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I enjoy Maps, as you can tell.
I'm actually curious about the
new version of Google Maps
that is now in testing stages.
Is that going to have another
version of Maps API that we'll
be expecting to come
down the pipeline?
JEZ FLETCHER: So we did announce
earlier, after the
keynote, we've done a visual
refresh of the JavaScript Maps
API, so it looks similar to the
visual experience you get
with the new Google Maps.
ENOCH LAU: Base tiles
are similar.
JEZ FLETCHER: Base tiles
ENOCH LAU: Controls are
refreshed, that kind of stuff.
JEZ FLETCHER: Controls are
refreshed, new markers, all of
this sort of thing.
In terms of other things, we
don't actually have anything
to announce at this time.
AUDIENCE: And would you expect
that there's going to be
something different?
Because there's some new events
that occur when you
have some of the things with
Google Maps that are new, such
as the streets getting bolded
up to a location that you've
selected or the slider events.
Are those events that we might
expect to see occur in a new
implementation?
ENOCH LAU: We're really excited
about what is coming
up in API in the future, but
we don't have anything to
announce right now.
AUDIENCE: Gotcha.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hi, everyone.
I'm Ho Ming, and I have
a question for Jack.
I'm very impressed for the tile
that you overlay on the
different platforms.
So I would like to know how do
you generate those tiles at
different levels?
Because there will be a very
hard loading, say, if you have
overlaid the zoom for the whole
San Francisco Bay area
or just for the tiles for San
Francisco downtown area.
Then the imprecision
of the tiles
generally would be different.
So I would like to know how do
you handle this kind of job in
order to minimize the bandwidth
or give better
presentation on your
applications.
JACK KWOK: So I'm not
sure I understand
the question correctly.
Are you asking what it takes to
generate the tiles with a
lot of coverage?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, and
the algorithm that
you use on the backend.
JACK KWOK: Right.
I mean the algorithm is really
specific to what heat map you
are making.
So for example, for our Crime
Map, we have partners that
provide us with crime data,
crime reports, and those are
in XML format.
And the logic, the algorithm to
make that into a colorful
heat map, that's really
something that is basically
really dependent on
what the data.
So generating a Crime Map is
very different from generating
a Commute Map or a Home
Evaluation Map.
AUDIENCE: No, no.
I'll put it in another way.
I mean for the precision of
the maps in generating an
overlay tile.
Say, for example, if you outline
the whole coastline of
the United States in a 1 to
1,000 scale would be far
different from 1 to 2,000,00.
The scale would be different,
and you
need different precision.
Because at the very high level
that you see the whole
America, you do not need a
very precise coastline,
because the user won't be able
to tell the difference between
1-10 vertex or 1-1,000 vertex.
So I'm asking in this aspect.
JACK KWOK: Right.
So the tiles are images.
They are not polygons.
There's no vertexes.
The tile is identified by three
numbers, X, Y, and zoom.
So when you're zooming further
in, it's actually a fetching a
new set of tiles with a
different zoom number with
basically the right
resolution.
So the farther up you are, the
tiles cover more area.
When you're zooming way in, like
to the maximum level, a
tile might be a block or
less than a block.
But when you're zooming all
the way out a tile is the
whole Earth.
So that's basically
how it works.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So thanks for your question.
JEZ FLETCHER: Any
other questions?
As always, there's a load of
great information on the
developer site for
Google Maps.
ENOCH LAU: And we'll be at the
Sandbox for the next 15
minutes or so as well, so come
and chat to us there.
JEZ FLETCHER: And thanks
very much.